hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
early on in the ethics of ambiguity
you'll see that simone de bevoir
talks quite a bit about the marxists and
before we go on to look at what she has
to say we
really need to stress that marxism
is not a monolithic you
look at a marxist over here and know
everything about marxist over here
sort of phenomenon and so it's always
important to contextualize by thinking
about
the situation in which an author is
writing if they're talking about
marxism i think from particularly for an
american
audience where there's never really been
a strong
marxist movement and where
they've been rather underrepresented you
could say
in the the humanities in general there's
been many people on the left but most of
them
not really marxists it's important to
understand that the marxists were a
significant a serious force not just
politically
not just economically not just socially
but also
intellectually in the time that that de
bevoir
is writing in france in france in
particular
and you know she also traveled to places
to observe how marxism played itself out
in practice over the course of her
life so when she's talking about the
marxists here
she means people both outside and within
the academy
who have a pretty substantive way of
looking at things and a program
in mind politically you know culturally
socially so when she's
considering the marxists here she is
examining their point of view in
relation to
the issue of freedom and you might say
by by doing that uh choice and
ambiguity as well and she's doing a
little bit of compare and contrast and
also
a bit of criticism now the marxist
criticized the existentialists as
philosophy
of freedom that was essentially
enshrining
bourgeois values and virtues
on the one hand or allowing too much
scope
for freedom on the other hand all of
which is really kind of illusory
and and at the same time there was you
know a lot of back and forth
between the marxists and the
existentialists since they did
recognize some points in common
she thinks that that marxism and
existentialism
share in common in particular this
notion of situation so we should talk a
little bit about that
we can talk about a general human
condition right
but we always exist
in determinate situations
in which we have to make decisions we
don't have
entire information about the whole world
and everything that we're choosing
there's a lot of
ambiguity on multiple levels this
is the nature of human beings this is
this is the human condition
where human beings exist and the
situations themselves
are not from like a panoply or book that
has
all of the 12 or 48 or 246 situations of
human beings listed
there's new ones coming into being all
the time and so
both existentialism and marxism are
recognizing this and they're also
recognizing what she calls
a separation we refer back what does
that separation
mean the separation of the human being
as they are as they exist from what they
would like to be
from perhaps their solidarity or
connection with other human beings
there's always a
disconnect there's always a disjunction
and
insofar as that disconnect is felt or
registered there's also
that's within us as well so the ideal
that we're not
is in a certain sense within us and also
separated from us
and we could come up with all sorts of
other examples of this so we don't need
to belabor that point
so she she has a lot of useful things to
say
about about this this issue here she
says that
we meet this in marxism which from one
point of view can be considered
as an apollosis of subjectivity that
means like it's really
embodying subjectivity she says that
marxism
like all radical humanism which that's
what a marxism is
at least you know until there was some
some anti-humanist marxism
in french thought later on but the
marxism of
her time is definitely radical humanism
marxism rejects the idea of an inhuman
objectivity and locates itself she says
in the tradition of kant
and hegel viewing human subjectivity
as something essential something
important history
as important intentionality as important
coordination development those things as
important
she also says unlike old utopian
socialism the socialism of the
enlightenment of the 1700s and 1800s
which confronted earthly order with
archetypes of justice order and good
things values that you could take for
granted as
objective marx does not consider that
certain human situations are in
themselves and absolutely preferable
to others so we don't
use those notions as you might say
starting points
right what do we do instead then
well how does the marxist understand
things
the needs of people now you could say
well there's a reduction to economic
needs
and that is true although within the
marxism
as we see it develop of her time there's
more than just
economics at play there's also the need
for recognition
there's the need for you know a certain
kind of
security you might say for being
involved in decision making
right so the needs of people the revolt
of a class
marxism you know in a certain sense is
kind of a universe
universalistic philosophy is a social
philosophy but it's always coming back
to
who is being exploited whose labor
and life is being consumed for the
benefit of
who who else how are these processes
which don't have to be set up this way
uh how are these processes constituted
how are they reproduced that's part of
what marxism
is focusing on and they they call that
class
back in in classical marxism the
proletariat the
working class the people who are
more and more impoverished more and more
uh treated as
just machines or animals not as human
more and more
finding their consciousness framed
within the situation that they're in and
so the revolt
is an action against us it blows things
up including the way to
look at things and these as she says
for marxists these uh define
the uh aims and and goals
she says it's from within a rejected
situation in the light of this rejection
a new state appears as desirable
so you know you start stop taking
capitalist economics and social
organization for granted and you say
well wait a second why do things have to
be set up this way
and this is a common phenomenon right
people
attain consciousness of their situation
and then once that's that's attained
then they can begin uh desiring and
therefore acting
differently so she says only the will of
human beings decides it's on the
basis of a certain individual act of
rooting itself in the historical and
economic world that this will thrust
itself toward the future and chooses a
perspective where such words as goal
progress
success failure action adversaries
instruments and obstacles
have a meaning this gives them a meaning
then certain acts can be regarded as
good and others is bad
so so far you know it looks like there's
a lot of you know connections between
existentialism which also rejects any a
priori
values or goods and says we have to
discover these as human beings
and marxism it looks like marxism is
just detailing a way
in which this this happens right so
as she says the goal and meaning of
actions then is defined by human wills
here's where the difference begins to
arise though she says
in marxism if it is true that the goal
and meaning of action are defined by
human wills
these wills do not appear as free
so that is so as we say some
serious daylight between the marxist
doctrine
and the existentialist doctrine the
existentialists say that our wills are
indeed free they're not free in the
sense that we can like automatically
choose to undo everything we've done in
the past or
any you know as we say here in america
anyone can become
president right your will does not
actually extend to that you can aspire
to it that's certainly something within
the scope of your will
but the existentialists were never
committed to you know crazy notions of
free will
they just say we actually we are we
exist as a freedom
we have choices even if they're choices
that seem rather restricted they are
still
choices within situations the marxists
say
yeah it's really an illusion what's
really going on here
is class consciousness
or what they called you know the
ideological superstructure the realm of
all
not just ideas but also institutions
like you know philosophy art law
culture all these are really being
determined by the economic basis
as it works out its contradictions as
new developments arise you don't really
have a free will you might feel like you
do but you don't really
so she says these are the red the
reflection of objective
conditions by which the situation of the
class or the people under consideration
is defined right
so in the present moment of the
development of capitalism the
proletariat cannot
help wanting its elimination as a class
now
you might say well why why would the
proletariat want its elimination as a
class
it means your life no longer sucking
right because that's what it means to be
the proletariat is you have very little
control over the conditions of your life
you're ranked very lowly in the social
structure your
yourself and your children will have
very little uh opportunities
uh and and options and you get your life
sucked out of you for the benefit of
other human beings who you may never
actually see why wouldn't somebody who
becomes conscious of that as a
fundamental human dynamic say
that sucks let's not do that anymore
that is
you know what's at stake for the
proletariat the question
that de bevoir is concerned with is
does the proletariat make any
contribution in deciding this
on its own or is that just they happen
to become aware of their situation
and by a sort of mechanical uh you know
there's no way out of it necessity they
now desire this and they now work for
this
because the marxists are depicting it
that way
so wills are merely the reflection of
objective
conditions or as she'll say a little bit
later
revolt need hope rejection desire
are only the resultants of external
forces and then here's a wonderful line
the psychology of behavior endeavors to
explain this
alchemy and i like that because you know
in a lot of cases marx's theory is
kind of like alchemy it's very
interesting but you're not sure
you know where things are actually
connecting with with the
supposed realities that we're looking at
in such a hard-nosed way
right there's a lot of idealism you can
say in
classical marxist analysis now she goes
on and she provides
an existentialist critique of marxism
here in this place and this is quite
interesting she points out a few
important factors that are being left
out so the first one is that freedom and
choice are still involved
how are freedom and choice still
involved well you know it's not as if
you just read the communist manifesto
and then start marching off again like
like some sort of
insect or machine you have to make a lot
of choices over and over again so she
provides you with some examples
of these in order to adhere to marxism
in order to enroll in a party and in one
rather than another to be actively
attached to it
even a marxist needs a decision
whose source is only in himself
so you know this is a typical
existentialist movement to say
yes you find marxism to be the correct
way to view things
yes you are choosing on that basis
but you have chosen the marxism that
you're following
and you say well i was convinced by the
data i was convinced by
you know reading the the manifesto or by
reading kapathol or by
having it explained to me in this class
or in this this party
uh session and you can say yes
you found that compelling because you
chose to find it compelling
on some fundamental basis you had to
make a commitment and that's okay
just acknowledge that there's nothing
outside of you
that actually made you choose this that
ultimately it comes down to you
perhaps saying something like i don't
like seeing people suffer
unnecessarily and marxism seems to be a
way
to understand and address that that's
fine that's coming from
you right you acknowledge it you take
you take credit for it that means that
freedom and choice
are still involved she goes on and she
says this
autonomy and she uses that word autonomy
there is not the privilege
of the intellectual or the bourgeois
and this is you know again targeting
marxist ideas
the bourgeois is somebody who can be
detached from things they can feel like
they're free the intellectual is
enjoying this privileged
life as opposed to the poor working
proletariat
who can't stop working to think about
these sorts of things they get home and
they're so tired
they just want to put their feet up have
a beer watch tv
and then you know hit the sack so they
can get up the next day and do it all
again
she ends up saying no the proletariat
gets to decide for
itself what kind of proletariat it's
going to be how do we know this
because there's different kinds she says
it can let itself be lured on
as happened to the german proletariat
what does she mean here
i think she's actually talking about um
not just you know things that were
happening uh prior to to
the the nazi regime and world war ii i
think she's actually talking about the
proletariat
in that regime and she's also talking
about um
uh you know the proletariat in in
in the german states in general and then
she talks about america
she says it can sleep in the dull
comfort which capitalism grants it as
does the american proletariat i mean
there's a sign right there
of the you could say the the weakness of
marxism
in america and you know how
why did the proletariat sleep or doze
off well because it's being offered all
sorts of consumer goods it's part of a
big social contract in which everybody's
boats are going to rise
provided of course that you're you know
of the right race
because there are many people being
excluded and terrorized
on that basis at the time right so the
proletariat
itself decides what it's going to do
what it's going to be
so it's there's still freedom there and
then she says in
practice marxists actually do appeal
to human beings as free agents
she says they don't deny freedom the
very notion of action would lose all
meaning if history were a mechanical
unrolling
in which we were only a passive
conductor of outside forces
by acting so that's one thing by
committing oneself in action
also by preaching action the marxist
revolutionary asserts himself as
a veritable agent he assumes himself
to be free and then she goes on and she
points out a third feature right so
in acting in preaching action and
advocating
and then in valorizing we could say she
she brings up the examples
of moralizing in the ways of you know
talking
about people taxing them with cowardice
lying selfishness veniality
right they very well mean to condemn
them in the name of a moralism superior
to history so when we're saying bad
things about people
these people should have stood up for
the strike and they didn't what a bunch
of gutless bastards they are
you're actually saying they had a choice
they could have done things differently
they have freedom
same thing when you're praising people
and you're saying you know
courage abner negation lucidity
integrity
right these are all uh good things she
says well you know it could be said
these are used for
propaganda their expedient language this
is to admit that this language is heard
that it awakens an
echo in the hearts of those to whom it
is addressed you can't
praise without there being something
that you think there is to be praised
even if you're praising falsely
just for propaganda purposes you're
still assuming freedom
as a marxist so she's saying the
marxists are are
in contradiction with themselves that
the existentialist position
or some sort of fusion of marxism and
existentialism would be
more accurate portrayal of the human
condition
which is one of freedom and choice right
within
situations and the last thing that that
she
brings up is um
that the marxist also condemn philosophy
freedom
on a different sort of ground she says
they declare authoritaria
authoritarially that the existence of
freedom would make
any concerted enterprise impossible so
any sort of committed or coordinated
action we can say that that's what
concerted here
really means the idea here
is that if you can't count on people's
wills
being basically determined you can't get
the marxist
project of revolt of class you know
raising of seizing the means of
production all these sorts of things you
can't get that off the ground
why not because anybody at any moment
could decide to follow their whims
because that's what freedom really comes
down to
is you can decide to do things
differently so if you're supposed to
strike for example
maybe you show up maybe you don't or
maybe you cross the picket line which
should be even
even worse right or you write a a letter
to the editor in the newspaper and
you're like this strike is is awful
right
that's possible for people and you know
the marxists are worried about this she
says that
according to them if the individual were
not constrained by the external world to
want this rather than that
there would be nothing to defend him
against his whims and
and you know this is really sort of a
basically
you could say it's a mistaken
understanding of human motivations
we're not by opening the door to freedom
we're not just
saying any possibility is is
substantively
possible we're saying things are
possible
people choose between them right but
they choose between them within
situations
and so you know she goes on and she says
uh marxist thought hesitates it sneers
at idealistic ethics which don't bite
into the world but it's scoffing
signifies there can be no ethics
outside of action not that action lowers
itself to the level of a simple
natural process it's evident the
revolutionary enterprise has a human
meaning and insofar as it has a human
meaning
it involves freedom and choice and the
existentialist position therefore
according to dubois cannot be gotten rid
of
by by the marxist critiques of it so
she's saying that the marxists are
getting some things
more right than other philosophical
positions but that existentialism
really understands the situation more
adequately
you